et la cyber dépendance est un des
nombreux aspects de ces cas de détresse
possible dans un contexte de pandémie on
a voulu approfondir la question avec
vous christine brouh présidente de
l'ordre des psychologues du québec
bonsoir alors d'entrée de jeu jusqu'à
quel point selon vous la santé mentale
la population sera plus fortement
touchées par les contraintes de vie que
nous impose le cette pandémie
bah écoutez c'est clair que déjà au
début de la pandémie ce qu'on disait
c'est il faut faire de la prévention
s'occuper de la santé mentale parce que
les difficultés ou la détresse qui peut
survenir vont durer plus longtemps que
la pandémie est elle-même ça va avoir
des méfaits qui vont potentiellement
être beaucoup plus long que la
propagation le on y explore plus tard il
faut il faut offrir des soins et
services
il faut les rendre universel parce que
beaucoup de jeunes dans la population en
ont besoin
mais ce sens et l'accès aux services qui
peut-être peut être problématique dans
le contexte actuel est-ce qu'il ya est
ce que c'est vraiment un peu si on veut
nous éloigner davantage de l'objectif
final épique est ce qu'on peut faire
pour contourner le problème
si on n'a pas accès à des soins comme
saint cruciaux pour bien des gens mais
en fait il foule
il faut justement affiche ainsi une
volonté du gouvernement actuellement de
donner accès de débloquer des fonds
justement pour donner accès aux soins et
services de santé mentale il faut
comprendre que il faut le faire dans une
large mesure c'est-à-dire que si pas
uniquement pour les gens qui sont des
joueurs sur les listes d'attentes du
réseau public parce que les gens qui
n'ont même pas accès à ces liquidateurs
à qui correspond aux critères donc faut
le faire justement là pour la population
en général peu comme une prestation
particulière je vous dise
on devrait offrir des services pour ceux
qui en ont besoin parce qu il y en a
quand même une bonne proportion de la
population actuellement le clip se
vulnérabiliser way et puis le premier
pas franchir c'est de reconnaître qu'on
est dans un état de détresse alors quels
sont les premiers signes des tout
premiers qu'on doit surveiller belle ici
qu'on observe le plus actuellement au
premier premier chef c'est l'anxiété
si vous avez accepté c'est une réaction
normale à la situation convient
totalement c'est à dire que ne pas être
eu ça se fait ce serait bien inquiétant
mais se le dit quand l'anxiété nous rend
dysfonctionnelle nous empêchent de
fonctionner nous torturent nous empêche
de dormir parce qu'on sait que l'anxiété
actuellement atteints une grosse
proportion de la population
on sait que les troubles de sommeil sont
assez plaisant aussi pau deuxième chef
on voit les éléments dépressif 16 les
éléments ont eu peur qu'ils font appeler
les gens sont découragés qui sont priest
qui commence à peine un petit peu espoir
on être cocus perdent un peu intérêt
alors quand est ce que on on voit
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas mais
c'est quand on voit un changement qui
est assez significative dans le
comportement de la personne dans sa
régulation effective dans ses
interactions avec les autres dans ses
consignes dans cette façon de voir la
vie et que ça persiste donc c'est plus
qu'une mauvaise journée c'est plus que
c'est plus qu'une mauvaise semaine ça
persiste pendant quelques semaines
consécutives
hélas ce moment le pays étant
effectivement d'aller chercher de l'aide
d'intervenir cela dit on et si on
devrait pas être être contrée d'attendre
que ça fasse tellement mal qu'on n'est
plus capable justement ou qu'on a pu les
ressources qu'on n'a plus l'énergie pour
faire les démarches pour pour aller
chercher il faut que l'aixois disponible
et accessible disponible et piquant
c'est pas le cas dans l'immédiat il ya
des conseils qu'on peut donner des
alternatives qui existent pour qu'on
puisse prendre soin de soi
en attendant d'être pris en charge mais
il ya une chose qu'on peut faire pour
prendre soin de soi dans la période de
pandémie pis il faut savoir ainsi que la
période ce sont des fêtes est une
période où étonnant
on voit une baisse de consultation
justement dans les sous sols de santé
mentale meilleur bon par contre en
janvier alors mais ce convoi qui le je
vous parle d'une étude mois que j'ai vu
dans clinical versailles en dessous
justement qui est un journal sérieux où
on voit que pendant des fêtes de façon
naturelle l'arc antillais aux potes
pandémie une tendance à la consommation
accrue de golf une tendance justement à
l'humeur du déficit pour beaucoup de
personnes
donc ça risque d'être amplifié cette
année mais se le dise il ya chose à
faire pour en former pour l'instant je
suis en dép garder une bonne hygiène de
vie d'une part resté actif physiquement
parce que ça aide beaucoup de sommeil
puis ça aide beaucoup l'humeur comme
écart ajustement de son tour et de ne
pas s'isoler savez quand on a des
mauvaises journées on a tendance à se
rouler en boule mais souvent si
préférable de faire c'est justement des
capable de communiquer avec des gens qui
ont la confiance de pas nécessairement
rester sur de possibles hic c'est
important aussi de rester actif
intellectuellement de limiter les
comportements qui peuvent être
potentiellement dommageable comme par
exemple la trop grande consommation
d'alcool piste important de ces ihu
aussi d'entretenir des passions ou de
trouver les refuges il faut se donner
des moments plaisir quotidiennement puis
il faut se déculpabiliser surtout ça
c'est très important se déculpabiliser
de pour répondre à tous nos objectifs
habitués alain c'est à dire que c'est
sûr qu'on n'était pas aussi productif
c'est surprenant
on n'est peut-être pas aussi de bonne
humeur c'est sûr qu'on était aussi
patients et ils font chez eux à redonner
son allardon et à ça ça fait partie de
prendre soin soit de révision de ses
objectifs puis de capable d'être
exigeant avec soi-même je voudrais puis
de prendre du recul et mais surtout
surtout de se demander mais ce que j'ai
eu mon môme au mazet
on m'a fait plaisir est ce que je me
suis permis de me détendre et j'ai
trouvé les bons moyens pour le faire
c'est les portes mais mais des fois on
sent qu'on rationalise bien ce genre de
choses là on sait qu'on doit le faire
mais c'est l'énergie qui nous montre la
motivation qui nous manque le petit coup
de pouce qu'on peut se donner soi-même
pour y parvenir
ben justement quand la motivation nous
manque c'est peut-être justement parce
qu'on sombre dans des éléments qui sont
un petit peu plus de substance de ce
format sombrer dans la dépression à ce
qu'on peut avoir un impact plus triste
sans être dans une dépression et dans ce
temps là justement ce qu'on se rend
compte c'est que plus on s'active plus
l'humour vie est donc ouvert quand on
n'a pas le goût quand on n'a pas
l'énergie ça vaut la peine d fois
d'aller prendre une grande marche
je ne dis pas que ça suffit tout le
temps mais ça aide beaucoup à se sentir
mieux comme de danser chanter de
dépenser de l'énergie de courir de de se
défouler ça peut faire beaucoup de bien
et parfois pleurer un bon coup c'est une
dépense énergétique qui ça peut aussi
faire beaucoup de bien ça peut être
apaisant avant dé foi de ceux de se
plonger dans une bonne série t il dans
un rom et pourquoi pas merci beaucoup
pour ce concert j'espère qu'ils auront
été utiles pour les ans les gens qui
nous écoutent merci ma langue au revoir
quelques zéros